we will begin with dr again thank you
hi
good morning and thank you corey
well we want to
to talk to you about the the recent
recommendation coming from the cdc and
the fda as you know yesterday
the the cdc advisory committee on
immunization practices
met to each to issue its guidelines for
a monitoring booth doses of pfizer
to certain populations
earlier this morning
the cdc director endorsed
those recommendations
and also recommended
a boosted dose for
for people who work on
high fees occupational institutional
settings
those those recommendations from the cdc
are aligned with the recent
recommendations
received from the fda
the cdc is recommending that the
following group receive the boosted dose
as at least six months after the the
second dose
those are people who are 65 years and
older
and residents of in long-term care
facilities
also people who are 50 to 64 years old
with underlying medical conditions
similarly
people who are 18 to 49 years old with
underlying medical conditions may
receive a booster
and then a people who are 18 to 64
years old and and they are working at
places or institutions where there is a
high risk of of exposure
and transmission will come
it is important to emphasize that
all those recommendations are
specifically for
for people who receive the fisa vaccine
so
those those recommendations that today
are not for people who receive the
joseon johnson or modern vaccine because
the cdc and fta have note yes we see the
the stories
supporting similar recommendations they
there are groups working on that
information once the information is
available for the federal
agencies they will make the
recommendation
and also
i also want to mention that that that we
southern nevada healthy street and our
community partners we have a kobe
vaccination clinics
located across across the county
actually we have a
15 locations in the county 12 10 are
right now a open entry all there are
functionality just waiting for
our
direction to open
and uh and of course are we were waiting
for
the stage
that they have a direction on when to
start with the with a boot
vaccination as recommended by the cdc
i i also
want to emphasize that
even so we are getting into this uh
incorporation of the of the vaccine
still
our our primary goal today
is to is to expand the
the vaccination to to those who are not
yet vaccinated that's our primary goal
and we will still keep working on that
and also we want to to say that even so
the federal government is offering those
booster vaccines uh
still the dolphins are considered highly
effective um the the main
target of vaccines is actually prevent
severity and death and and this is
something that
all three vaccines have been
shown to be highly effective
we we we encourage every any person in
triad county who has not been vaccinated
yet to please
go to any of our vaccination centers or
the local pharmacies um
and ask for the vaccine that is very
important for us uh
as many as you know
in drug county more than 85 percent of
the people who are being diagnosed
recovered or being admitted because of
covet or die
because of kobe they are people who have
not received a single dose of
vaccination
and i will stop here now and i'm
recording we will open for questions
at this time we will take one question
from each member of the media if anyone
wishes to ask one of course please raise
your hand using the raised hand feature
if you're on the computer uh you can
find that feature at the bottom of the
participants list but if you're just
calling in please press star nine
at this time our first question comes
from mary hines
good
morning so once you have the go ahead
from the state to be giving the third
doses
will an 18 year old casino worker or
grocery store clerk be able to get a
third dose
and is anybody going to be required to
prove that they qualify
okay
do you want you want to say that or
sure uh so the guidelines uh say
if you are in a um
[Music]
increased risk of exposure and
transmission because of occupational or
institutional setting
we're still receiving got going to
receive guidance about that issue from
the state so that's what we're waiting
for is a little more clarity on that
type of uh what that exactly means
um the individual will
look at their own benefits and risk and
of course that will weigh in on that as
well
as far as proving uh that at um
sites we have not yet determined what we
will do so far um
like we did for immunocompromise we
didn't we just had them um
self attest that they had a medical
condition and we'll do that with
underlying health conditions as well
thank you joanne um as we go through the
questions for everyone please be sure to
identify yourself and the media outlet
you work with please
jaclyn schultz you are next
please go ahead jack oh
there you go
thank you
hi folks uh jacqueline with fox5 uh
would you be able to tell us how many
people we think might need
a
booster how many people we're talking
about here and
how important is it to speak to your
doctor
about
whether you need a booster
okay
um
well i wouldn't start
i don't have the numbers in front of me
i don't know if joanna or sarah have
those numbers but we do have the number
of people
who vaccinated through the different uh
priority groups that were
decided at the beginning of the
vaccination campaign
and and those numbers will guide us on
actually the the planning of these
phases of the campaign
um
this i don't remember the second part of
the question where i was
um
but talking to your doctor
correct exactly in terms of
in terms of determining who who should
and who's really
at risk and who's high risk
okay
okay you want to talk about that
please
okay great they they just sent me to me
great thank you for that um
i'm sorry can you please repeat the
question
about the
people who who might want to be
vaccinated
you know
why should they talk to the doctor what
they should talk to a doctor about
yeah certainly so um the guidance we got
so far
specifically related to folks with
underlying conditions is that
those underlying conditions are fairly
extensive and cdc has a list of those
conditions on their website
and we will certainly make that
information available to the public
um
but but certainly uh if folks have
questions about whether or not their uh
health conditions or underlying health
conditions qualifies them for booster
dose or if they have questions about the
the need for a booster dose
and certainly we recommend they talk to
their individual provider about that
our next question today is from caitlin
newberg
hi everyone um this is caitlin with the
review journal um the health district's
data website is showing that case
averages and the averages for deaths
have been decreasing in recent weeks is
it safe to say that the peak we saw over
the summer has ended and how significant
have vaccinations been in decreasing the
metrics
sure thank you
yes actually if you look at the at the
charts in our west side
you could see that the the the trend of
coveting in cloud county is is is really
decreasing since probably about
four or five weeks ago
and uh and of course also when you look
at the positivity rate seven day
positivity rate of code testing in
tri-county uh that
trend is also uh
decreasing
our positivity rate
about five weeks ago was
18
and today that positivity rate is uh 8.2
8.3
so
what it means is that there is a
decrease in incoming transmission in in
our community
and of course that also translate on
on on the proportion of people
who
who are fascinated who could actually
develop the disease and separate through
cases
uh
the the higher the
the transmission level in the community
the higher fees of people even if they
are fully vaccinated to
to develop the disease uh
i mentioned before what we have seen in
krakowing
so far is that about 15 percent of of
the cases that are reported are fully
vaccinated that
that's that's the trend that we have
seen
initially
in june
it was about
about three to five percent
when when we started with with increase
in the sorts on cases but i say at that
a
a wave going up the
the proportion of vaccinated cases also
went up but uh right now
as we can see increasingly transmission
level in clark county that have been
kind of level of about 15 to 17 percent
of the cases being fully vaccinated
which
again is is not unexpected we
when we look at those numbers
we see that
again mortality hospitalization
among people who are fully vaccinated is
is almost normal
i believe we have interaction
one death per
more than 10 000 vaccinated people which
is
about 40 times
less than what you see in unvaccinated
people
and uh and the same when you look at the
at the at the incidence of the reporting
of new cases
we we are seeing about
70 to 80
bucks a fully vaccinated people who
actually
are
infected
will pretend to have some people so it's
it's the numbers are really small and
are really
confirming how effective the vaccine is
still here
thank you
our next question today is from jeff
gilliam
um good morning everybody uh jeff gillan
here channel three news um uh
this is to dr lagann or to anyone else
on the panel here what ex how exactly do
you do you foresee this this campaign
this booster campaign rolling out are
you just going to be using
now the existing
assets the pharmacies the doctor's
offices or do you do you expect to
um as we saw earlier in the vaccination
campaign to any sort of large sites for
boosters how actually do you do you plan
to
uh roll this out
yeah
you want sarah
yeah go ahead sarah on this one she's
she's got this down pat
there we go
thanks for asking so at this time with
our static sites that we have up it's
exactly what we're looking at is that
with in addition to the pharmacies and
the grocery stores and the targets and
the other stores that have it or the
doctor's offices that have it we have 12
static sites that are already up that
has an untapped capacity of what we're
getting at right now we have about 20 of
the capacity being filled with people
getting vaccinated so we have room for
more people to come with this additional
dose in the booster doses coming
in addition we also have the ability
with or position to be able to scale up
quickly if it's needed
so everyone will be getting their
vaccine
where they're getting wherever they got
their first or second dose
you don't necessarily have to go back to
that provider
that has changed since people got
vaccines back in january and february
uh right now you can get that dose
anywhere so any pharmacy
any any of our sites uh we we just
revised our web page
so that you can put in your zip code and
you can go right to
whatever is in your neighborhood or
wherever your workplace is so
we really encourage the public to really
take advantage of that
if any member of the media who has um
not yet asked a question but wants to um
please raise your hand remember the
raised hand feature
is at the bottom of the participants
list or if you're on the phone hit star
nine we are gonna take a follow-up
question from mary at this time
thank you
what is your best estimate then
in terms of when people will be
able to get the third shot
if someone went to one of your clinics
today could they get a third shot is
your or is your best estimate sometime
next week
people are champion at the bit to get
this third shot
they sure are so
um for our clinic specifically
we are probably going to wait till like
later next week but they could try to um
access it at the pharmacies or other
sites as well
all of the providers have their own
systems in place and their own uh ways
of
getting that
in place but
um i know a lot of people will probably
be waiting for that uh state guidance
um this is jennifer can we provide some
clarification about the third doses
versus the boosters for people as well
right so we're talking about a booster
dose
and so that means that someone has
received the primary series as we say so
the first and second dose and this is a
booster dose six months after the second
one
so this is different than one uh that is
called a additional dose
for immunocompromised people
if you recall in august that was
recommended 28 days after the second
dose and that's part of the series it's
uh to
make sure that those
people whose immune systems aren't
working real well that they get another
dose to kind of get that immune system
going so the booster doses after the
immunity wanes
and um and then we boost it and uh bring
those antibodies back up
does that help any
yeah
and those are currently available
in our clinics
the ones for the immuno compromised yes
absolutely we've been doing that for
almost a month
thank you joanne let's take one
follow-up from jeff and then any closing
comments from the panelists before we
move on to the spanish section
jeff one last question please ah yes uh
thank you again um let's talk about
supply since now booster shots gonna be
people will want uh booster shots how's
the supply of vaccine um do you have
enough
any any concerns or that's not really an
issue at this point
yeah right now it's not been an issue uh
we haven't had supply issues for a while
you know in the beginning they were just
getting the manufacturing up so we did
have a lot of you know limitations with
that but not at this time
the type of vaccine
there's been some issues with johnson
and johnson but we still have enough
supply
for anybody that wants their first dose
second dose or um subsequent doses
thank you joanne does anyone else on the
panel have any closing remarks before we
end the english portion of this briefing
well um thank you cody again i just want
to emphasize that
our primary target
today
still is that people who have not
received any those of the vaccine that's
the unvaccinated people that that's the
people that we are really looking at
today
but uh
they boost their
doses that will be offering
very soon
hopefully starting next week
are very important as well
but
it doesn't mean that they are seeing is
not effective we we know that that they
were seeing is very effective especially
in terms of preventing hospitalization
and death and there is a lot of data
already supporting that so i just wanted
to make that comment thank you
thank you joanne and sarah and dr loaf
that wraps up the english portion of
this briefing